i think that a lot of what you're saying
here uh both the bitcoin and the gold
community are pointing and saying like
hey this has got long-term implications
that either one may not be understood or
too maybe way worse than uh we're
willing to admit to ourselves now their
trade-off with the long-term
implications is the short-term need to
address the current situation and so i
likened this to back in march of 2020
april and may where central bankers and
politicians came together and they said
hey there's a pandemic going on there's
a financial recession that is underway
uh we feel the need to make the
trade-off between the short-term
you know pain mitigation and whatever
the long-term consequences are we'll
deal with those later now you me many
people in the gold and bitcoin
communities all yelled and screamed and
said hey the long-term implications of
this are going to be really really bad
we should be more thoughtful about what
actions we take in the short term they
didn't do that they ended up going ahead
and pumping trillions of dollars into
the economy manipulating interest rates
doing all the asset purchases etc we
then saw that play out that was and that
was the worst
possible
monetary fiscal response they should
have done the opposite they should have
recognized a contraction and economic
activity required a contraction and
money supply
uh so that prices would be stable and so
that we would encourage people to
consume more uh while they were
producing less we needed people who were
less productive to reduce their
consumption uh you know we needed to
sacrifice in order to win a war uh
against against a virus the way we've
sacrificed in the past to win other wars
or we should have found another way
uh about about you know what another way
to do it i mean if we weren't willing to
pay the cost then we shouldn't have had
the lockdowns you know we should have
found a different approach to dealing
with uh the health threat but if we
wanted to do it the way we did if we
wanted to send everybody home and have
nobody go to work and nobody produced
then we had to accept the fact that a
severe recession was gonna accompany
that and not try to you know have our
cake and eat it too and say hey nobody's
gonna work we're all gonna stay home but
we're not gonna have a recession because
we're going to print all this money
and let everybody go and spend it that
was the worst possible combination of
policies and i was very critical of it
when it happened and now we're just
seeing the beginning of the results this
isn't the end
we're we're gonna see much bigger
increases in consumer prices uh in 2022
than we saw in 2021 and we're going to
see probably even bigger increases in
2023 i mean this is the tip of an
iceberg all right so if we look at what
they did in march april may and all the
way through 2020 into 2021 we now are
seeing the impacts of that to your point
40-year high in inflation yeah yeah yeah
when we started more than 40. you know
it's it's they're not measuring it right
you know we're not using the same cpi we
used 40 years ago of course now if we
look at what's going on in terms of
these sanctions i think a very similar
type of framework is playing out where
we're trying to mitigate short-term pain
at the expense of long-term implications
and so what those long-term implications
are you described help me understand uh
when we start to also think not just of
the currencies but it seems like we've
made in the past
short-term decisions at the expense of
long-term implications around
oil and natural gas and we now have seen
the united states and many other
countries give up energy independence or
slow down their pursuit of energy
independence for environmental reasons
or elsewhere and now it seems like
russia is in a very unique position
they're the third largest oil producer
in the world they produce 17 of all
natural gas in the world uh and at the
same time that we are trying to sanction
them uh and be quite abrasive from a
economic and monetary standpoint we're
still having to buy
much of their oil and natural gas
because all of these countries are
dependent on it
what do you think happens to oil prices
and gasoline in the united states or
other consumption
globally for that type of commodity well
prices are going up i've been saying
this for years we've been under
investing and you know the politicians
have been trying to push us into this
green direction
prematurely i mean you have to let the
free market dictate uh the the type of
energy that you're gonna use and if
you're trying to force
uh uneconomical forms of energy on the
public there are gonna be ramifications
now certainly in the long run you know
humanity is not going to exist on fossil
fuels forever right at some point we
won't use them at all
but i don't know when that point is but
i know that we're nowhere near it now i
know that the science and technology
hasn't advanced to the point
uh that we can that we can move away
from it but you know i mean
at one point i mean
all of our fuel was coming from from
whales right how would we get oil where
we went we were harpooning whales right
so and but but we got oil oil and
natural gas we didn't have to do that
anymore so that was a big positive i
think most people don't want to go back
to the days of whaling uh to to try to
you know to to get to get light uh but
at some point you know there's going to
be uh more stuff in solar
and and wind or who knows what they're
going to do
but right now oil and gas coal those
type of fuels are still the most
economical ways of generating the power
that we need and to the extent that we
haven't been developing it as much as
other countries
that is a problem you know and and the
governments have created these barriers
and that the result of that is a lower
standard of living you know if we're
going to go for the green new deal or
anything like that
the public has to know that there's a
huge cost associated with with that you
can't just you know they try to market
it as if it's going to be great news
we're going to have this green new deal
and everybody's going to be better off
no everybody's going to be worse off
that's the trade-off you want to go
green
you know you're going to go poor because
you're not going to have the standard of
living that you have when when we're not
not green but you know
the real problem is not going to be
these prices going up as far as
inflation is concerned i mean the big
increase we're seeing in food and energy
prices this is going to cause a
recession this doesn't cause inflation
because as food prices go up as energy
prices go up consumers have to spend
more of their incomes on those
necessities they don't stop eating uh
you know they still need uh to heat
their homes uh electrify their homes
they need to drive so money is going to
be spent you know at the supermarket but
that money can't be spent someplace else
and it's the reduction in other spending
that ends up causing recession then of
course the federal reserve responds to
that by printing more money and that's
where the inflation comes from not from
the isolated increase in certain prices
but from the fact that the federal
reserve will end up compensating for
that in fact in many cases what happens
is oil prices go up food prices go up
and the federal reserve thinks oh we
need to print more money so people can
afford to pay those higher prices and so
but now that drives the prices even
higher because we don't need more money
we need more food we need more energy
but the federal reserve doesn't create
any of that it just prints money hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time